نحن حاليا داخل المطار وخاصه قسم الجوازات
في مطار جيبوتي الدولي وصل عدد من
المواطنين الذين تم اجلائهم من السودان
بعضهم حامله الجوازات المزدوجه السودانيين
ويحملون جوازات بعضها بريطانيه وبعضها
كنديه وايضا هناك ايضا رعايه من من
اليابان ومن امريكا ومن بريطانيا وتم
اجلاؤهم من احد المطارات العسكريه القريبه
والله كانت
مخاطرهم في مطار عسكري اسمه وادي سيدنا
مطار في ام درمان
الناس بتيجي من اتجاهات الطريق ما فيها
مخاطر كثيره جدا لانه الطريق طويل جدا
فالطريق في جزء من الطريق ما مسيطره عليه
الدعم السريع
وطريق نص الطريق الثاني في الجيش
فيمكن تحصل الاشتباكات في اي لحظه
فعشان كده محفوظ بدل المخاطر ايوه نعم
معظم الناس انا متاكد كثار ناس ما حدا
يقدر تطلع لاني بالنسبه للمخاطره في بعض
الناس اطفال مع الناس كبار اذا حصلت اي
حاجه حصلت في الطريق
اخيرا وصل هؤلاء الى بر الامان وصلوا الى
مدينه جيبوتي لكن كثير منهم قلوبهم لا
زالت هناك عند في السودان عند ذويهم الذين
يقولون ما زالوا عالقين تحت
الاشتباكات والظروف الصعبه التي تمر بها
الخرطوم ويتحدثون ان الوصول الى الاماكن
الاجلاء هي عمليه محفوفه بالمخاطر كان
لابد من ان يخوضوها
الجزيره من داخل مطار جبوه الدوله